i'm not like a regular mom i'm a cool
mom it's no secret that hollywood is
obsessed with youth
and this is never more obvious when it
comes to casting parents
we've seen it time and again 25 year old
teenagers with 30 year old parents
hello the oc and gossip girl but
sometimes the age gap goes even further
so much so that sometimes the children
are actually
older than their parents let's take a
look at some of the tiniest age gaps
between on-screen parents and their m
children
that is jenny's mom i know
ginny in georgia is about a
mother-daughter duo who share a bond
despite being polar opposites in real
life they have more in common than it
seems
and might be better suited to playing
sisters rather than mother and child
sure they are supposed to only be 15
years apart a la gill more girls but
with bigger boobs
but in real life it's a whole lot less
when the show premiered the actress who
plays ginny and tonia gentry was 24
years old
and her mom georgia played by brienne
howie was 31
that's only 7 years tear jerker
phenomenon this is us
is famous for the way it jumps forward
and backwards in time to tell the
family's epic story
because of this and the fact that they
don't recast the older versions of the
characters
the ages of the cast don't always line
up especially when it comes to rebecca
played by mandy moore
when the show hit the airwaves moore was
32 years old and her children
sterling k brown chrissy matz and justin
hartley were 39 35 and 38
respectively don't be shy becca drop the
skincare routine
i accidentally inseminated you two weeks
ago you what
jane the virgin is another example of a
show that features a mother and daughter
who are pretty close in age
jane's mother zamara gave birth to her
daughter just before her 17th birthday
and was in her 40s when the show began
even so we were totally surprised to
hear that the actress who plays her
andrea novetto is only 7 years older
than jane actress
gina rodriguez i've been 17 years old
since 1864. anytime vampires get
involved the age of the actors who play
them always gets a little interesting
which makes sense seeing as how there
aren't many 150 year old actors working
today
but even the humans can't escape the
weirdness of hollywood casting
like in this prime example from the
vampire diaries
in the show david anders plays john
gilbert elena's father
but in real life it turns out that
andres is only eight years older than
his tv daughter nina dobrev
and of course it's not because he's
immortal
hello brother damon and stefan salvatore
have a complicated past
to say the least but when it comes to
their casting things get even more
odd stefan is played by paul wesley who
was 27 when he was first cast in the
series
and ian somerhalder was 31. the crazy
part is
their mother played by annie worshing
was only 32 when the show
started that makes her six years older
than paul and only
one year older than ian we know vampires
are supposed to be young but
come on okay so the 2011 sci-fi movie in
time takes place in a world where
everyone stops aging at 25.
so it made sense to cast a younger
actress to play justin timberlake's mom
but we were still surprised to find out
that olivia wilde who got the role
is actually three years younger than
timberlake when they
shot the film during shooting justin was
30 and his mother
olivia wilde was the ripe old age of 27.
i was sure i'd have a grandchild by now
once again we're back at vampires in
twilight breaking dawn parts 1 and 2 we
get to see bella and edward have their
daughter
now it totally makes sense in the world
of the movie that the 18 year old bella
would have a teenage daughter because of
the fact that the children of vampires
age at an accelerated rate
growth rate is unprecedented but that
doesn't make it look any less strange
kristen stewart was also only 18 when
she shot breaking dawn part 2
and her on-screen daughter mackenzie foy
was 12.
common knowledge by now that rachel
mcadams was actually 26 when she played
the teen queen regina george and mean
girls
all the way back in 2004 but did you
know that her hilariously inappropriate
mom
played by amy poehler was only 33 at the
time
that means that the surgically enhanced
mrs george was only seven years older
than her on-screen daughter
you girls keep me young when the new
nancy drew started out
17 year old nancy was played by 23 year
old kennedy mcmahon
i was nancy drew girl detective of
horseshoe bay
so here's a nancy drew mystery for you
how old was the woman who played her
adoptive mom
catherine drew here's the story on the
show
we learned that catherine was the high
school guidance counselor to nancy's
birth mom
who passed away during childbirth when
she was 17.
katherine took nancy in and raised her
as her own
before passing away herself years later
catherine was played by actress sarah
canning who was only 32 during filming
making her what that's right nine years
older than nancy
the 20-year time jump in outlander meant
that the cast had to start incorporating
wigs and makeup in order to make them
appear
older than they actually were and it
made for one particularly funny
mother-daughter age gap
nell hudson who's played leary since the
first season of outlander
had two daughters with another man and
then married jaime
under dress on his part after claire
goes back to her own time
and when claire comes back it's safe to
say leary
isn't exactly thrilled it also means
that nell is only
two years older than one of her
on-screen daughters played by lauren
lyle
on the netflix favorite orange is the
new black elizabeth rodriguez plays
elita diaz
mother of diana diaz brenda yours
no it's my mom while elita had dia when
she was young
they are not even close to the right
ages in real life it turns out
dasha polanco who plays diaz is not even
two years younger than elizabeth
one year and 11 months to be exact
elita's supposed to be in our late 40s
but was only 34 when the show started i
guess i
live under a lucky star tim rosen played
mutt on the first three seasons of
shit's creek
the son of roland and joycelyn and
alexis's brief love interest
when she first spotted mutt and his mom
alexis accidentally thought they were
dating
well that might have actually made more
sense than them being mother and son
turns out that in real life jennifer
robertson is only five years older than
tim
when the show started she was 43 and
rosen was 38.
anyways while both angelina jolie and
colin farrell
might like us to forget their period
epic and box office
bomb alexander there is one detail we
just can't shake
and that is the fact that angelina jolie
was only 29 when she was cast as
the then 28 year old farrell's mom
yep his mom you birthed me sack of hate
she wasn't even a full 12 months older
than him during the filming
there's no denying that she's an amazing
actress and has always been beyond her
years
but this kind of casting is exactly why
cosmetics and anti-aging skin care is a
500 billion
dollar industry in 2019's glass
actress charlene woodard plays samuel l
jackson's mom
i'm 88 years old in this show it was an
amazing performance
but we were totally shocked to learn
that charlene was only 64.
but jackson himself was actually 70
during filming
that means that the woman playing his
mother was 5 years younger than him
[Music]
there's no denying that heath ledger was
absolutely amazing as cowboy annis
delmar in brokeback mountain
the film follows ennis and the love of
his life jack for almost
two decades and in that time ennis has a
daughter
who was played by kate mara because
heath played the older and younger
versions of ennis and was aged over time
with makeup
it worked out that mara would be only
four years younger than her dad when
they filmed their scenes together
even though he was only a couple years
older he really took me under his wing
with all of this information it's really
no surprise that our perception of age
has been totally messed up by hollywood
angelina jolie is colin farrell's mom it
makes no sense
but what do you think do you buy it even
a little we'd love to know